okay so the bad batch season 2 is now at
the halfway point and we have a double
Bill episode that's definitely my
favorite storyline that we've had in
both seasons so far this to me is the
level of a political thriller filled
with twists turns and big reveals that
speaks to the landscape that now exists
in the Galaxy there's so much good stuff
to talk about and throughout this video
we're going to be going through both
episodes 7 and 8 scene by scene this
video includes Easter eggs hidden
details and everything you need to know
about the entries if you enjoy it please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day by the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the bad
batch season 2.
now the main reason I think this was a
two-parter was because the first episode
doesn't contain the bad batch at all
it's also of course the mid-season and
with that comes several Revelations and
turns for the story I think that they
didn't want to lose the focus of the
show too much and instead want us to
give us a double bell send it around the
same tale to keep us invested for the
next half either way both really knock
it out of the park and we get some big
appearances by Bale or Ghana Captain Rex
and Emperor Palpatine voiced by Ian
McDonald who sees the Clones are pushed
one step closer to Oblivion with pulps
are showing a new era with the Imperial
Stormtrooper all Palpatine needed was
approval from the Senate furre and he's
Rampart as a patsy to carry this out and
the first episode is called the Clone
conspiracy with Alana being titled truth
and consequences the first could be
dealing with the number of aspects such
as the conspiracy around the Clones to
replace them but also because the Clones
suspect that something else is going on
be bigger on coruscan outside a bar and
this looks similar the one from the
start of attack of the Clones the
episode follows a similar sort of motif
with a sniper killing someone outside
just like what happened with Django
Fett's assassin Wessel at the front of
it we can catch a Twilight and inside an
ad Droid serving up drinks to the clone
troopers here we joined two who help
bombard to Poker City and since then
ramparts covered up the attack with lies
and deception he said that storms are
the location and we know from visiting
the planet that it was rampot with these
and the waves go Sky High and apparently
the platforms were flooded with rain and
this idea is what's used to cover up
what really happened however jet fuel
doesn't melt steel beams and those
platforms were built to withstand the
waves so that's a lie now for
those involved in it it hasn't sat well
either have you been following our
breakdowns and you know how we've talked
about one of the major themes in the
season being that of Independence to
batch themselves of course represent
this there was Wilco in episode 2
Commander Cody and even some of the
enemy separatists have now started to
seem like the good guys be because they
don't want to join the Imperials I will
learn one of the soldiers is called
sleep and he just wants to slip under
the radar whilst his mate has stupidly
messaged Rampart giving him an ultimatum
he said he could come clean himself or
that he would do it but you dumb son of
a that you've just given the guy a
heads up now slip is a nickname that's
appeared in The Saga so far there was a
first order Stormtrooper who served
under Captain phasma with the nickname
but the two are unconnected and it is a
pretty common nickname to be fair a slip
says that the attack on title cassetti
was just following orders and this is a
catchphrase that's of course popped up
throughout the Star Wars Canon we were
following orders oh were we could
soldiers full of orders could soldiers
follow orders could soldiers follow
orders good soldiers follow orders
Rampart even says something similar at
the end of episode 8 and he was very
much used as a pawn much like how the
Clones were stay back I was following
orders
now outside the Assassin's strikes but
slip manages to slip away so I'll I'll
stop me I'll stop slip manages to slip
away and we get him riding off into the
traffic again riffing on this scene from
Attack of the Clones the Assassin is
later revealed to be a clone himself and
this is very much a Gemini man situation
where they have ones that are built
purely for Black Ops he follows orders
without question and to me very much
represents the possible person that
cross-air could end up becoming at the
curse of his friends and family he's
given up his freedom to bring what he
sees his order the Galaxy and even
Rampart looks down on him he spent
months and months on kamino and it was
only by chance that passes by came and
got him it is possible that these were
sent by Rampart to help build the cover
story and he stayed loyal to the Empire
even after being part of the destruction
he saw firsthand what they were willing
to do to him and his people and he's not
an imperial he's a simp perial so a
swell stop
can't help myself sometimes I'm actually
interested to see what happens with
Crosshair now though as taking Rampart
out massively shuffles the deck anyway
we then could the Senate whereas in the
past this has been shown on its own we
get a bit of symbolism here with the
Star Destroyers in the sky after the
occupation of desex we saw one over it
and this is echoed in the scene in Rogue
one that happens on Jedi it signals
who's really in charge here and we know
from this vantage point that they are in
control in the past it's from this
position that they've rained down fire
and destroyed entire locations and now
they probably wouldn't do that in the
Senate it's ominous for a reason inside
we see an Ishita who says that due to
the destruction of kamino that the
Galactic Empire is now vulnerable this
allows the Stormtroopers to be suggested
later on and it shows how in control of
everything that Palpatine is Rand Paul
wants to push his recruitment bill which
will mean more citizens are forced to
serve and this will save the Imperials
money as they no longer have to make
clones we see a Gotham senator who
mentions the banking Clan and they were
brought up by the Clones in episode 3.
there's also senator pamlo who has
appeared before on live action during
Rogue one lastly we have melogana who
needs no introduction and they'll
they'll fill the more it doesn't really
sound that much like Jimmy Schmidt it's
good to see the character back he brings
up the emergency Powers Act and this is
summing it appeared in Revenge of the
seats so that Palpatine could gain
control this shifted the Republic into a
military organization and made it a far
cry from what it used to be Belle wants
to hear from the emperor himself but
sitting in his place is mazumetta who
you'll likely recognize being the
emperor's right-hand alien debuting in
Phantom Menace he's watched Palpatine
game power over the decades and has
benefited from his manipulative tactics
lastly we see Senator chuchi who becomes
a big part of the two episodes Chichi
first appeared in the Clone Wars episode
trespass and she's popped up in 16 of
them all together the pantorum
politician helped the Jedi throughout
and no doubt seeing them wiped out
really struck in there with her she's
here to say clone lives matter and there
could be clear comments to how soldiers
are cast to the side after the wars are
over Rambo practically built an entire
franchise around this idea and those
that came back from Vietnam were called
baby killers and looked down upon even
though they gave up so much when
fighting overseas they just casted the
side and the Senate wants to focus on
the new Army instead of caring for the
older one Rampart says there are things
in place whilst the Clones are phased
out but we saw an Obi-Wan that was a
homeless one which kind of tells you all
you need to know the vote is tabled and
Mars warns Rampart that if anyone finds
out what happened on kamino that it's
curtains for him in classic Palpatine
right hand man style ameta's warning
comes with him saying for your sake
Emerald be certain there are no more
surprises which is ripping on when Darth
Vader said it in Return of the Jedi I
hope so commander for your sake back at
the bar we see chuchi trying to pitch
the pension plans of the Clones but they
want to keep fighting they were born and
bred for one thing and having that taken
away from them has left them with
nothing else to really live for one of
them says I'd rather be out there
fighting those Insurgent groups that
keep popping up
who this is we don't know but it's
possible that it might be either so
Guerrera or possibly Lutheran's early
Rebellion the Empire completely
overlooked these and ultimately a letter
that downfall when they could have had
soldiers out there stamping them down
Rampart also later talks to chuchi about
the growing rebellion and I like how
this is seated throughout the entire
episode now eventually they learn to
draw his Chichi and want to receive her
help sled decides to go to her and I
love how sketchy he is in the doorway
this is the area his friend gotchan
killed at and he's clearly scared about
stepping out he tells her about the
Garrison and the conspiracy to cover it
up by killing and reassigning those that
would speak up slip slips through the
street and we see a roadie in before he
sends out a distress called the Captain
Rex Rampart says that he will agree to
the terms and states that he was on a
training exercise off-world which is why
he couldn't help out training exercise
at this point are a bit of a running
joke in movies and TV shows the military
was dropping it as far back as Iron Man
to cover up what was actually going on
now at this point Chichi goes into the
underworld and she's greeted by r2c4 C4
pops up later in the Saga and he's
eventually saved by Poe Dameron in an
offshoot story which is when he joins
the resistance led to Balor Ghana the
pair want to get slip to testify and
this will finally reveal the truth to
the Senate Rampart instructs the
Assassin handles slip and the senator
which is when he makes his move whilst
the two meet slip once up from Rex to
escape and as we all know he managed to
avoid the reach of the Empire after the
end of the Clone Wars now the Assassin
takes out slip after he tells Chichi
where the information is and Rex arrives
in the nick of time so he can save the
day revealed to be a clone he bites down
on the Star Wars version of a cyanide
pill and ends his life before he's made
to talk further again it's very similar
to Gemini man and which has been an
extra layer of covert cloning going on
so that special Troopers can be created
to be assigned a secret of jobs anyway
that takes us in episode 8 which as we
said title truth in sequences beginning
on Old mantel we see Omega trying to
meditate like a Jedi ever since season
one there's been these theories that
Omega is force sensitive and that this
is the reason why she was created in the
first place I did think for a long time
that she was made in order to make the
building blocks for Palpatine returning
somehow but she doesn't really seem to
have the abilities that the Jedi do
ganji taught her how to meditate but it
doesn't help however this might change
as the season goes on we see gunky the
gunk Droid and Echo also mentions skako
Miner this is a reference to Clone Wars
season 7 episode 2 when he was saved by
Captain Rex he was used as a pawn by the
separatists and though he says he joined
the batch because that's where he fit in
we see how this change has come the end
and the waiting around for Sid and we
still don't know exactly what's going on
with her there were some clues that
something was off but we'll see how that
develops later down the line Rex sends
out a call for help and they end up
going to the heart of the Empire which
is where things will be at their most
danger
coruscan is breathtaking and true
omega's eyes we see The Wonder of the
city after meeting with Rex and Chichi
they're shown the Assassin who has had
all of his identifying numbers
completely removed the Macho cause
antiboka City when it was destroyed and
this Mission becomes very personal for
the group where the only record being
around parts of Anita they end up
heading out there whilst chuchi gives
Omega a tour of the Senate she says that
clones don't have representation in
there even though the laws of it affect
them directly I might be wrong on this
uh so correct me if I am but I'm pretty
sure that Puerto Rico doesn't have
representation in Congress even though
it's part of the us also I don't know
why I said Puerto Rico there trying to
sound cool but clearly didn't work now
that might be me making connections that
aren't there but I thought I'd just
bring enough and if I'm right then I'm
right and yes it hit it on the head but
if I'm wrong forget this part of the
video the Chichi is basically a
character that stands up to the Senate's
bureaucracy which is similar how Padme
did it during the prequel trilogy
Omega recommends speaking to Holly
batoni and this is the senator of the
planet kamino she first appeared in the
clone wars during The Duchess of
Mandalore entry and we learned that
she's been Outcast since the attack he
recommends following the money and shout
outs still added a map upon either this
could be a reference to All the
President's Men just follow the money
now in an apartment similar the one that
Padme had an attack of the Clones she
gets petone to speak to her after Omega
tells her the truth of what happened on
kamino but only his Watcher species Fade
Into Obscurity and in season one we saw
CAD Bane take a mega to a rundown
cloning facility that had two faded out
turns out Rampart did divert the funds
away from the Clone facilities and they
need Bitoni to testify this in the
Senate near ramparts veneda who watches
the batch make a break for the plans and
C clone troopers using massive similar
to Tuscan Raiders the Star Wars answered
the dogs and they used to sniff out
anyone that could be seeking through the
area I also think there's a lot of
droids and Rex mentions record heading
Heights which was first brought up in
the distant Echoes episode in in which
he was saved after hanging off the
transport they get on board and there
are moments are pulled directly from the
rest of the Saga doors slide open the
ship and we see how blasting the door
panel can indeed lock it or unlock it
depending what you need at the time
it'll do either one the batch once more
use stumbler so that they don't harm
their brothers and well to keep things
PG-13 we see v-wings mounting up and
these are the ships that Omega was
studying back in episode one of the
Season using the guns on board the vened
air they shoot down some and Echo Fires
at the engines to make sure the Troopers
Evacuate the area they then launch
several Escape pods and the batch
managed to make it off the ship the fast
way back in the Senate rampart's pretty
much put on trial and Omega races to
them with evidence of his operations the
shows his attack at the end of season 1
from a new angle and it's there in black
and white well blue and white but moving
on Palpatine rises from the ground at
this point and this is done in a similar
way to the shot and Revenge of the Sith
this is the first time we've seen the
character in the bad bat since his
hologram in episode 1 and I have to
admit it was chilling watching him
arrive I don't know why but you never
really expect to see the big names in
the show and it was like when Nick Fury
popped up in Agents of Shield anyway
he's arrested by some stock trimmers
which we can see from their red and
white uniforms they were basically the
police on coruscan and they were the
gods of the planet hideous Galactic
peacekeepers also I think it's important
to point out that the whole following
orders thing is is what the Nazis said
during the Nuremberg trials when they
were asked why they committed such
heinous acts like the prequel trilogy
palpatines managed to play both sides
and the fact that the Clones followed
Rampart so blindly is what he thinks
most worrying oh man he had this
installed on them so that they could
carry out with a 66 without question and
in one file swooby puts things in place
to get rid of them he makes it seem like
a kindness whilst ushering in this new
legislation and there will be
Stormtroopers from this point on it
completely nullifies the clones and a
big question you might have is why would
Palpatine do this well as we've been
discussing the Clones are slowly
starting to think for themselves and it
might be better to just wipe the Slate
clean they're asking why they've killed
the Jedi and this seed of Doubt could
Fester into something more now in a
goodbye we watch as Echo decides to
rejoin Rex and help the Clones later in
the timeline we know that Rex pops up in
Rebels along with wolf and Gregor and
though Echo isn't with them he does say
to Omega that he'll be back at some
point to this goodbye it may not last
forever but it does feel a bit
devastating seeing him go off now we end
with Omega hugging her took a doll and
it's such a summer way to close out
these episodes I don't know why but
knowing what we know makes us feel like
a big loss another group managed to get
rid of rampart it doesn't feel like a
win with hindsight we know what's coming
for the clones and just out of it's
gonna be for them to exist in the Galaxy
they had it bad but things are about to
get a lot worse and they're being pushed
out even more than before having
palpatino showing the Stormtroopers felt
like a big blow and even though he knew
it was coming I can't help but feel it's
tragic anyway that ends the episode and
as you probably can guess thumb sang a
lot I really enjoyed it obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it too so
make sure comment below and let me know
if you are in competition right now
giving away wakanda forever to three
subscribers on the 15th of February and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe notifications on drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
episodes repeat the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter heavy spoilers if you want
someone else to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of The Last of
Us which will be linked on the screen
right now lots of things to talk about
lots of cool Easter eggs things going on
so definitely get over there right after
this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been poor see you
next time take care peace